So,
uh,
before we go on to talk a little
bit about the American historicist,
a hermeneutical scholar,
ed Hirsch and Wolfgang Eser,
uh, for whom you have your
reading assignment. Uh,
I want to go back to God them are a little
bit and say something more about his
taste.
That is to say the kind of literary and
intellectual cannon that his approach to
hermeneutics establishes.
You. Remember, God,
Amar is very much concerned
with the norm of classicism,
which later in his essay he's
inclined to call tradition instead.
Uh,
and the reason that that's so important
to him is that he actually has a very
conservative view of what the reader
can accomplish in understanding another
horizon. God, him or in other words,
does think that the reader can perform
any great miracles and intuitively
feeling his or her way into the mind of
another time and place so that the value
of classicism and of tradition for God
or is that there is evident common ground
in certain texts.
Sometimes we refer to them as great books.
In other words,
the sort of text that speaks,
or we feel as though it's
speaking to all places and times,
of course it's contested whether
or not there's really any,
any merit in talking about texts that way.
But God and his view is very strongly
that this conservatism about the cannon,
which is intimately related
to his conservatism,
has doubt about the actual capability
of a reader to span enormous gaps.
And I use that word advisedly because
it is the word that ease of uses, uh,
to talk about the distance between the
reader and the text and the way in which
that in the way in which that
distance it should be negotiated.
So in any case, um, this
conservatism, it seems to me,
however,
can be questioned and I thought that
we'd begin then by turning to page seven
31, uh, the lefthand
column, the footnote, uh,
you're beginning to realize,
I'm sure that I like footnotes a given
of course was said to have lived his life
in his footnotes.
Perhaps I live my life in the
footnotes of other people. In any case,
in this footnote, God
ever says something. I,
I think it's very rare that
we can actually just sort
of outright disagree with
God over.
But he says nothing in this footnote
that I believe we can actually disagree
with. Toward the bottom of the footnote
seven 31 lefthand column, he says,
just as in conversation,
we understand irony to the extent to
which we are in agreement on the subject
with the other person.
We understand irony only he means to
the extent to which we are in agreement
with the other person.
If you are expressing an
opinion and otherwise,
which differs radically from my own.
I can't understand according to gardener
whether or not you're being ironic.
This seems to me to be
just patently false. Uh,
think about politics.
Think about political talk shows,
think about political campaigns when
our political opponent is being ironic
about our views. We understand the
irony perfectly. Well, we're used to it.
Uh, we have accommodated ourselves to it.
And of course it's the same in reverse.
Our opponent understands
are ironies and there is,
it seems to me a perfect
kind of symbiosis,
ironically enough between
political opponents. Precisely.
Maybe in the measure to which they're
ironies are mutually intelligible.
It probably teaches each of them
are good deal, uh, to accommodate,
to encounter,
to get used to the ironies of the other.
And I think this applies
to conversation in general.
It's very easy to pick up most
forms of irony we don't have,
we don't have an enormous
difficulty grasping them.
And it doesn't seem to me that our
capability of grasping irony is founded on
unnecessary underlying agreement.
That's what he's saying.
Now, if this is the case,
it seems to me that one has found a
loophole and got him or his conservatism
about what the reader can do.
His premise is that in order to understand
there has to be a basis of agreement.
But if what we've just said about
understanding each other's ironies,
even where there is pretty
wholesale disagreement is true,
that ought to apply also to our
capacity to read work that with which we
distinctly disagree with, which we
feel we can never come to terms, uh,
in terms of affirming it's value,
but which we nevertheless can understand
if understanding is not predicated on
agreement,
the possibility of opening up the Canon,
as we say,
insisting that it doesn't have to be an
absolutely continuous traditional cannon
is available to us once again and got,
or his conservatism on this
issue can be questioned now.
It's not the gardener's insisting
on absolute continuity on contrary.
You'll probably remember that
on page seven 32, um, it,
the, the, uh, um, the,
it can't be seven 32,
so please disregard that. I'm not going
to read this passage anyway. Uh, uh,
he says early in the essay that in
order to recognize that we are in the
presence of something that isn't merely
within our own historical horizon,
we need to be pulled up short.
In other words,
to go back to that example
once more, the, um,
we need to recognize that
there's something weird
about that word plastic. Um,
and in being pulled up short,
we recognize the need also for the
fundamental act of reading and God umber,
which is the merger of horizons with the,
in other words that we are dealing
knowingly with the horizon,
not altogether our own.
That has to be negotiated,
that has to be merged with our own
for understanding to be possible.
So got her. In fact, God,
we're even insist that if we don't have
this phenomenon of being pulled up short,
our reading is basically
just solid cystic. We,
we just take it for granted that what
we're reading is completely within our own
horizon.
Um,
and we don't make any effort at all to
understand that which is fundamentally,
or at least in some ways different
God I'm or acknowledges this,
even insist on it as I say,
but he doesn't lay stress on it because
the gap that is implied in the need to
be pulled up short is not a big one that
has to say it's one that we can easily
satisfy plastic again. Oh Gee,
that's a strange word we say.
So we go to the OED,
we see it meant something different than
our problem is solved and we continue.
No big deal, right? But there
may be a ways of being pulled up,
short occasions for being co pulled up
short that God of Earth thinks exceed the
imaginative grasp of a reader.
And this,
as you'll see when we return to ease
or after I've said a few things about
Hershey,
this as you'll see,
is the fundamental difference between
God and man and or where it gut wherefore
God them or the gap between reader and
text between my horizon and the horizon
of the text isn't it?
Is perforce a small one for either,
it needs to be a much larger one in
order for what he calls the act of the
reader, the Reading Act really
to swing into high gear.
And we'll see that this has implications
for the obvious difference between
their two cannons.
All right,
but now I want to say something about
the person who, the passage of whom,
uh, I quoted over against
the passage from God.
I'm at the end of the God and or a
lecture you remember got him or said, um,
we have to be open to the
otherness of the past.
Uh, and, and in order that
for us it may speak true,
but if we simply bracket
out our own feelings, uh,
that can't possibly happen.
So that we have to recognize that in
this mutuality of the reading experience,
we really are in a conversation.
We're open to being told
something true by someone else.
Hirsch on the other hand
says, oh, well, you know,
the important thing is to know the
exact meaning of that other person,
because that's the only way to honor
the otherness of the person. You know,
concepts people ought to be, uh,
an end and not a means for us.
We ought to understand them on their
terms, God and or his claim, however,
was that if we do that,
we are in fact suspending the way in
which it might be that they speak true.
We're sitting,
we're,
we're honoring instead the integrity of
what we're saying without thinking about
whether or not it might be true.
So I introduced Hirsch in that context
and now I want to go back to him a little
bit. Uh, and I want to
work with two passages,
which I've sent you all an email form,
which I've neglected to put on the board,
but there is so short,
I don't think that will be necessary.
The first of the two passages I want to
talk about is Hershey's argument that
consciousness is an of that meaning is
an affair of consciousness and not have
words.
Meaning is an affair of
consciousness and not have words.
In other words,
the text is what makes the ascertainment
of meaning possible and available to
us.
But meaning is not in the text.
Meaning is in the intention of the author.
And that is the,
and that is what we need to arrive
at as we work through the text.
Meaning is an affair of consciousness
and not have words. Now think about this.
What it means is that
in understanding a text,
we are attempting to grasp it.
In paraphrase,
we are,
in other words attempting to grasp it
in a sentence that might read something
like what the author
means to say is right.
That is it. So that it's a,
it's not what the text means,
which might be anything according to her.
She,
if you've just appealed to the text,
it's what the author means to say is,
okay,
so what's implied here?
On the one hand you can say this is just
absolute total nonsense and we use a
text to find meaning and something
that we don't have available to us.
Why don't we just find meaning in the
checks which is available to us? Uh,
that would make more sense. It's
up to us to construe the text. Um,
we can't possibly know what the author
meant except on the basis of our
determination of the meaning of the text,
so why not just focus our
attention to meaning on the text.
Hirsch was a student of whimsy at Harris,
was engaged in lifelong
that's agreement with God,
but he was a student at wounds,
wounds that the author of
the intentional fallacy,
obviously Hirsch was a rebellious student
and insisted that far from wanting to
take websites.
Position appealing to intention was
the most important thing you can do.
The only thing you can do,
which establishes according to the
title of his first important book on
Hermeneutics, validity in
interpretation. All right.
Now it seems it's very difficult.
It's very difficult intuitively to assent
to Hershey's position and I'll just
tell you by the way that I don't,
I can't,
but I will say in passing in defense of
Hirsch that if we reflect on the matter,
we realized that in common sense terms,
appealing to an author's intention
is precisely what we do for practical
reasons. Let me give you an
example. You're all students.
You are sitting in classrooms that in
many cases oblige you to take exams.
Your instructor tells you
when you write your exam,
don't just para the words of
the authors you're studying.
I wanted, I want to know that
you understand those offers.
Think about it.
You prove to your teacher
that you understand the
authors by being able to put
their meaning. In other
words, in other words,
to say the author is
intending to say something,
not just that the text says something and
this is what it says it's at with your
exam. Then you know one
long screed of quotation.
Ironically, the the, the,
the instructor doesn't really
want just quotation on an exam.
He wants explanation and the form
of explanation is paraphrase.
You can't have paraphrase unless
you can identify a meaning,
which is interpersonal meaning,
which can be shared among a group
that understands and can be expressed.
In other words, that's the
key. If you can put it,
in other words,
those other words take the
form of an appeal to intention.
All right, so that's, and
that's an important point.
Argument in Hirsch's favor.
We realized that practically speaking,
the necessity of appealing to
paraphrase in order to guarantee mutual
understanding certainly does seem to
be something like agreeing or admitting
that meaning is an affair
of consciousness, not of
words. My consciousness,
the author's consciousness,
the consciousness that we can all share.
That's where we find meaning and
meaning takes the form of that kind of
paragraph paraphrase that everyone
can agree on so much then,
uh, to the, uh,
to the t to the advantage
or benefit of Hirsch.
Uh, there are lots of things to be
said against it. On the other hand,
which I don't want to pause
over now because I think a,
a course of lectures and literary theory
will inevitably show the ways in which
paraphrase is inadequate to the
task of rigorous interpretation.
Clans, Brooks, uh, the new critic, uh, uh,
rights of famous essay called
the heresy of paraphrase,
insisting that a proper literary
interpretation is a wooden mechanical
inflexible exercise if it reduces the
incredible complexity of a textual
surface. To paraphrase. Um,
and so it's a complex issue.
Uh, and I should, I should
leave it. Having said this much,
leave at x at least for the moment.
Now, one other thing that her says,
the other thing that I uh, that
I quoted, um, is in effect,
I'll paraphrase now that uh,
that uh,
that what got them or omits to realize
is that there is a difference between the
meaning of a text and the significance
of a text that is Hirsch's other key
position. And we can understand
it by saying something like this.
The meaning of a text is
what the author intended it.
To me that is to say what we can
establish with a reliable paraphrase.
The significance of the text,
which Hirsch does not deny interest
to the significance of the text is the
meaning for us.
That is to say what we take to
be important about this meaning,
uh, the way in which for example, we
can translate it into our own terms.
Historically we can adapt it to a
cause or a or an intellectual position.
The ways, in other words in which we can
take the meaning of a text and make it
significant for us,
the difference between meaning and
significance then is something that purse
takes very seriously and he insists
and here's of course where it becomes
controversial.
He insists that it's possible to tell
the difference between meaning and
significance if good basis that you are,
you can pin down accurately
an incontestably the
author's meaning appealing to
all the philological tricks that you have,
uh,
throwing out irrelevancies and insisting
that you finally have the meaning.
Right? And of course, how
many times has that happened,
which is obviously one
point of disagreement with
hers and insisting that you
finally have the meaning, right?
Then once you've done that,
once you've secured the integrity
and accuracy of the meaning,
her says, okay, fine. Now you can do
anything you like with the text. You know,
you can adapt it for any,
any sort of possible purpose.
But the crucial thing is to keep
the distinction between meaning and
significance.
Clear obviously got 'em or refuses,
refuses to argue that we can
distinguish in that way reliably.
We don't know because it's a
question of merging horizons.
My horizon in the horizon of the tax,
we don't know with any guarantee where
meaning leaves off and insignificance
begins so that the splitting apart of
the two terms is something that simply
can't be accomplished by the way in which
we enter the hermaneutic circle that's
got hammers position.
Uh,
and it is the position of
anyone who supposes that, uh,
Hirsch, uh, although the,
once again, the distinction,
what he means by that distinction
is clear enough. Yes, yes. You say,
I see exactly what he means.
Nevertheless,
that to secure the distinction
is that in actual practice say,
okay, this is the meaning and now this
is how I'm going to make it significant.
Well, you know, it seems unlikely indeed,
that this is something anyone could
ever accomplish. All right? Finally,
to turn to Wolfgang easier
ease or is concerned with what
he calls the act of the reader.
Does.
AHC does lasers a as the title
of one of his books and he is an,
and in so doing,
he establishes himself as a person very
much in the tradition of phenomenology,
deriving from Husserl more directly in
[inaudible] case from a an analyst of the
way in which the reader moves
from sentence to sentence
and negotiating a text,
a Polish intellectual named Roman in
garden who is quoted frequently in the
essay that you have. Um, those are
the primary influences on either,
but he himself has been tremendously
influential in turn reader's interest in
the reader. There's interest
in the reader's experience, uh,
is part of a school of thought that he
helped to found that grew up around the
university of Constance in
the sixties and seventies, uh,
which resulted in a series of seminars
on what was called reception history or
alternatively the aesthetics
of reception and ease.
Or his colleague was Hans
Robella [inaudible] whom
we will be reading later in
the course.
Uh,
the influence of the so called constant
school spread to the United States,
uh, and had many ramifications
here, uh, particularly, uh,
and crucially in the early work of
another critic will be turning to later in
this semester, Stanley fish. Uh,
so reception history has been
a kind of partly theoretical,
partly scholarly field,
uh,
one that's really still flourishing
ever since the early work in the great
Constance seminars of Eser.
Uh, yes and others. So,
and easier later in his career.
He died just a couple of years ago,
later in his career, taught annually
at a university of California, Irvine.
And by that time he was very much
engaged in a new aspect of his project,
uh, which he called the anthropology
of fiction. That is to say,
why do we have fiction?
Why do we tell stories to each other?
All of eases work is grounded in
the notion of literature as fiction.
He's almost exclusively a scholar
of the novel. And by the way,
one of the first obvious differences,
uh,
you can notice between Eser and got
her is that whereas God omers and
intellectual historian who's canonical
texts are works of philosophy,
uh, works of social thought, uh, as
well as great works of Literature,
uh, for easier. It's a
completely different canon.
He has exclusively concerned with fiction
and how we read fiction and how we
come to understand fiction and how
we determine the meaning of a work of
fiction.
And as I say in the,
in the last phase of his career when he
started thinking about the anthropology
of fiction, he raised the even
more fundamental question.
I think a very important one though,
not necessarily to be aimed
exclusively at fiction. Uh,
the anthropological question,
why we have fiction at all,
why it has been a preexisting
trans historical phenomenon
of human culture that
we tell stories to each other,
that we make things up. Uh,
when after all, when after all we
could be spending all of our time.
Well just talking about things
that actually are around us.
How is it that we feel the need
to make things up? All right.
Now as you read easier,
you'll see immediately that he in tone
and in and in a sense of what's important
and his understanding of the way in which
we negotiate the world of texts that
he much more closely
gossamer than Hershey.
We can say this in two different ways.
We can say that [inaudible]
position is a way is,
is a reconstruction of what got him or
says has essentially to say about the
merger of horizons. For
example, on page 1002,
a the bottom of the left hand column
over to the right hand column,
he says,
the convergence of texts and reader,
the convergence of text
and reader got him,
or his way of putting that would be
the merger of the uh, readers horizon.
My horizon with the horizon within
which the text appears either says the
convergence of text and reader brings
the literary work into existence.
This is implied in God Amar as well.
It's not your horizon,
it's not my horizon.
It's that effective history which
takes place when our horizons merge.
That is the locus of meaning for Ghana.
By the same token,
for what what,
what [inaudible] is saying is that the
space of meaning is virtual and this is
the word he uses. It's neither
in the taxed nor in the reader,
but the result of the negotiation back
and forth between the text and the
reader,
he says,
sort of brings the literary work
into existence in a virtual space.
And this convergence can
never be precisely pinpointed,
but must always remain virtual and is
not to be identified either with the
reality of the text or with the
individual disposition of the reader.
So you'll see this has got a mirror in.
This is the result.
This is the fruit of they hermaneutic
engagement between horizons that results
in meaning,
let's put in a different way by his there.
But it is in a large degree the same idea.
He also plainly shares with God.
They assumption the supposition that
the construal of meaning cannot be all
together. Objective, in other
words, is there is no more, uh,
and historicist then God I'm or is,
but insist rather on this mutual exchange
of prejudice between the two horizons
in question.
So he argues on page 1005,
the right hand column
one text,
this is halfway down the column one
text is potentially capable of several
different realizations and no reading
can ever exhaust the full potential for
each individual reader will
fill in the gaps in his own way.
And this of course brings us to the issue
of gaps and the role that they play,
uh,
in the act of reading as
ease or understands it a gap.
It's an interesting term.
I don't know.
I don't actually know whether
either to be Hershey and means,
uh,
what I'm about to say about gaps,
but plainly a gap isn't a bit,
so it's a distance between two points.
But what's really interesting
is that we think of spark plugs.
We think of gapping a spark plug.
In other words,
I don't know if you know how the
spark plug words but, but, but,
but for the electrical current to
fly into operation and a spark plug,
the two points of contact
have to be gapped.
They have to be forced apart
to a certain degree. Too much.
There's no spark too little. There is
no to too little you short out, right?
There's no spark.
So you have to gap a spark plug.
And it seems to me that the Aha effect
of reading the movement back and forth
across the gap between the reader and
the text can be understood in terms of a
spark, right? As though the relationship
between the reader and the text where the
relationship between the
two points of a spark plug,
whether God Umer means that when he speaks
of gap or whether he simply means and
a bis or distance to be
crossed. I couldn't say. Um,
but I think it's useful. Uh, you know,
like the opportunities in the word
plastic. I think it's useful, uh,
to suggest that the sense of gapping as
spark club may have some relevance to
our understanding of what goes on in this,
in this reading process.
Now,
how then does he differ from
God are one way that is I think,
not terribly important but I think is
interesting in view of what we've just
been saying about Hershey and another
way that's absolutely crucial that we've
implied already and to which we need
to return the way that's perhaps not
terribly important,
at least for president present purposes.
Although this is a distinction that's
going to be coming up again and again
later in the semester is the way in
which he actually seems to distinguish.
This is page 1006, uh, in the, uh,
how can it be? I've got it,
uh, in the um, uh, yeah,
in the upper left hand column,
the way in which he appears to distinguish
between reading and interpretation,
very top of the left hand column.
He says the text refers back
directly to our own preconceptions.
Got them or would call those prejudices
to our own preconceptions which are
revealed by the act of interpretation.
That is a basic element
of the reading process.
So there's a wedge there between the
concept of reading and the concept of
interpretation.
I would suggest that it's not unlike
the wedge that her drives between the
concept of meaning and
the concept of Inter of,
of significance and meaning is construal
significance is the application of that
construal to something.
I think that the distinction is,
is making between reading
an interpretation can be
understood in much the same
way is or doesn't make much of
the distinction. In other words,
it's not an important part of
his object of his argument,
which is why I say that the difference
with gardener who never makes the
distinction between reading
and interpretation. Uh,
the difference we've got 'em
or in this matter is slight.
But the other difference is very important
and that is to return to this point
that eser stresses innovation
as the principle of value
governing the choice and
the interpretive strategies of reading
innovation is what easier as Canon is
looking for. That's what makes it so
different from God. Numerous conservative,
continuous,
traditional cannon is as
understanding of gapping.
The spark plug is a much more bold,
uh,
affirmative of the imaginative
powers of the reader.
A much more bold process than the uh,
hesitant conservative process
suggested by God ever.
Now in order,
in order to illustrate the way in which,
what ease or calls virtual
work gets done in this regard,
let me just run through
a few passages quickly.
If God ever says in a way that PR that
he doesn't really stress in the long run,
that in order to know that there is
actually a difference between the reader's
horizon and the horizon of the text,
you need to be pulled up short.
Something needs to surprise you.
Well easier throws his whole
emphasis on this element of surprise.
If it doesn't surprise, it isn't worth
it, it doesn't have value. And we'll,
and we'll talk in more detail about the
ways in which it doesn't have value in a
minute.
So the gap,
if the element of surprise is to become
absolutely central and paramount in the
reading process, the gap has
to get bigger. The the, you
know, there just has to be,
it has to be a bigger distance,
a broader of bits.
And that's what either is working with
in the passages I'm about to quote,
as I said, I'm going to quote
three more or less rapid fire.
The first is on page 1003,
the upper left hand column in
this process of creativity,
that is to say the way in which a text
induces the feeling of surprise in the
reader.
In this process of creativity,
the text may either go not
far enough or may go too far.
Now I admit in this particular passage,
you get a hint of God, hammers,
element of conservatism. The text
may go through far. In other words,
it may make demands on us
that are too great. Yeah,
we're reading Finnegan's wake.
We haven't got a clue. You know,
the text has gone too far. Uh,
we can't get from sentence to sentence.
Even within the sentence,
we have no idea what the words
mean. And so we're at sea, uh, uh,
unless of course we really
rise to meet the challenge,
but typically are characteristically
it in [inaudible] terms,
the text has gone too far.
So we may say he elaborates here.
So we may say that boredom and
overstrain form the boundaries,
the on which the reader will
leave the field of play.
And that as if there are no surprises,
that's just the Yon. I mean,
why bother to read it all and
at the surprises are too great.
They induce overstrain. Uh,
and we throw away the book, um,
in frustration and despair.
Uh,
and so the distance of the gap needs to
be between the outer limits of boredom
and overstrain according to
according to Eser page 1004,
the upper right hand column
expectations and this word
is, uh, what, uh, eser thanks.
The sort of dialectic that the reading
process is playing with reading consists
according to his,
her,
and the violation of expectations
for the violation to work.
The expectations have to be there.
So that's the dialectic.
That's what's negotiated.
The,
there has to be a sense moving from
sentence to sentence that something is
likely to happen next.
If that underlying sense isn't there,
then whatever happens is
simply met with frustration.
But if we have the expectation that
something's going to happen next and then
something different happens or if the
suspense of wondering what will happen
next is in play so that anything can
happen and it and, and, and, and the but,
but but the experience is suspense,
um,
has been gone through then in those cases,
that's all to the good.
That's a good part of the reading process.
Expectations says eser are scarcely
ever fulfilled in truly literary texts.
You see,
that's where the evaluative principle
that completely revolutionizes got
hammers. Cannon comes in. In other words,
innovation is that the
principle of change,
the principle of violated expectation
is what imposes or establishes value and
the literary text,
not continuity,
not a sense that across the abyss
truth is being spoken to us,
but rather the sense that across the
abyss we are being constructively
surprised. Right? That's that,
that that's what has changed between,
between these two positions.
We implicitly demand of expository text.
He goes on and he may be alluding to God,
I'm are here because after all,
God Ameren is talking primarily about
expository text works of Philosophy,
works of social thought, which of course
aren't trying to surprise or trickest.
They're trying to lay out an argument
which is consistent and continuous, um,
and keeps surprise to a minimum. It's
difficult philosophy and social thought,
but it's not difficult because
of the element of surprise,
but it's the vocabulary.
It's the complexity of the thought
and so on that makes it difficult.
So easily said and easily
acknowledges this. He says, uh, uh,
we implicitly demand of expository
text that there be no surprise,
um, as we refer to the objects
they're meant to present,
but it's a defect in a literary text.
That's the difference for Eason between
nonfiction and fiction and nonfiction.
We don't want to be
surprised. It has other, it,
it poses other kinds of difficulty,
let's say. But in the case of fiction,
in order to be engaged, in order to
enter the hermaneutic circle properly,
we need the element of surprise.
So as I say,
a way of distinguishing between
fiction and nonfiction. Page 10, 10,
the lower right hand column,
the word defund linearization we will
encounter soon when we take up the Russian
formalists.
D familiarization means precisely
pulling you up short or taking you by
surprise,
making you,
making you feel that what you thought
was going to be the case or what you
thought was the state of affairs
is not the state of affairs.
Uh,
Wallace,
the poet Wallace Stevens
puts it beautifully when
he says that poetry should
make the visible a little hard to see.
In other words,
it should be a d familiarizing of
that which has become too familiar.
That's an aspect of the reading process.
And so is her says this d familiarization
of what the reader thought he
recognized is bound to create attention
that will intensify his expectations as
well as his distrust of those
expectations. In other words,
the tension itself of simultaneously
having expectations and feeling that they
should be valid, violated the
probably they will be violated,
being on the alert for how
they're going to be violated.
This is a kind of tension,
a constructive tension,
which constitutes for either the
psychological excitement of reading.
All right.
Having said all of this,
obviously what easy means to say is
that the reader should work hard.
There should be that the virtual work
done by the reader to constitute,
to bring into existence a virtual meaning,
uh,
should be hard work and there's not much
work to do if two things are the case,
first of all, if the techs just
seems real, in other words, if,
if it's, it is, if there's
no spin on reality,
if there is no sense of
this being a fictive world,
if it's just seems to be about the every
day about life as we live at the life
that we find ourselves in according
to ease, or at least there are no,
there are no, there's no violation of
expectations. The gap isn't big enough.
This is of course disputable.
There is a kind of a vogue recurrently
and the history of fiction for a kind of
a miraculous sense that this is
just exactly the way things are.
People enjoy that in ways that ease or
may not be fully acknowledging in this
argument,
but there's no question that it doesn't
involve the violation of expectations.
There's not much gap at all.
It's another kind of pleasure that re
that either is perhaps not taking into
account that we take in that which seems
to be simply incontestably real as we
read it. Uh, and and easier leaves
that out of account. On the other hand,
he says that there is no use either a no
value either in that form of engagement
with the text in which an illusion is
perpetually sustained and that it's an
illusion is created a never,
never land is created.
We know it's an illusion,
but we get to live in it so comfortably
with so little alteration of the nature
of the illusion or of the way in which
we negotiate the illusory world that it
becomes kind of womb like
and cozy. Uh, it is, I mean,
and here of course either is referring
to what he calls culinary fiction.
The very, the, the sub genres of
literature like, well, nurse novels,
bodice, rippers, uh, uh,
certain kinds of, of,
of detective fiction.
Although a lot of detective fiction is
much better than than that description
would imply.
In other words,
novels in which undoubtedly it's an
illusory world just don't happen the way
they happen in nurse novels and
bought us for a prison. You know,
somehow or another, you know, the pauper
marries the prince. This doesn't happen.
But at the same time,
it's a world of illusion in which
the reader lives all to comfortably.
Right. So these are forms
of reading, of the reading,
of the experience of reading fiction,
of which either disapproves
because there's no work being done.
The virtual work of the reader
does not involve surprise,
does not involve the
violation of expectations.
The relationship between text and
reader must be a collaboration.
Eser argues the poly
semantic nature of the text.
That is to say the fact that the
text sort of throws up all sorts of
possibilities of meaning. If
it's a good text, the policy,
romantic nature of the text and the
illusion making of the reader are opposed
factors.
In other words,
there's something in the raider that
wants to settle comfortably into the world
of the nurse novel,
the Bodice ripper,
the formulaic detective novel wants just
to sort of exist comfortably in those
worlds,
but a good taxed.
It's perpetually bringing the reader up
short and preventing that comfort zone
from establishing itself.
So that the tension between the,
the,
the tendency on our part to sustain an
illusion and the way in which the rate of
the tax keeps undermining
the illusion is again,
that aspect of the
psychological excitement of
reading that ease or wants to
concentrate on.
Now a word about then Tony,
the tow truck in this regard.
Um, I brought the text with me.
Uh,
you can look at it now or at your leisure
and I wanted to call attention to a
few places in the text in which it is a
question of expectation and of the
way in which this expectation can be
violated.
Now,
it's only fair to say that if we're
going to read Tony seriously in this way,
we have to put ourselves
in the shoes of a toddler.
That is to say as readers or
auditors, we have to, we, you know,
we have to think of ourselves and
of the psychological excitement of
experiencing with text as that
of a toddler. Uh, we, you know,
and it's not so very difficult
to do. For example, um,
I'm Tony if tow truck,
I live in the little yellow Varage
I helped cars that has stuck.
I told them to my garage. I
liked my job one day. I am stuck.
Who will help Tony the tow truck.
All right.
Now this is a wonderful example of the
tension between having expectations x
with the expectation that someone
will help Tony and being in a state of
suspense,
not knowing who it will be.
Now from the adult point of view,
this is culinary because we know that
we're in the world of folklore and that in
folklore everything happens three times.
We know that two vehicles are going
to come along and not help Tony.
And that the third vehicle will,
because everything, as I say, ah,
but happens in threes in folklore.
And Notice Tony the tow truck next week
when we read the Russian formalists,
uh, we will, we will learn, uh,
the research finding or one of the early
formulas to the effect that repetition
in verse is analogous to
Tautology in folklore.
We have exactly that going on in
Tony the tow truck Tuck, Tuck, Tuck,
and then the three events, Nido, the
car, speed of the car, bumpy, the car,
uh,
you know,
it's coming along and sequence and
bumping finally resolving the problem.
So in any case, we, we,
we have an expectation.
We have the dialectic of suspense.
On the one hand,
how will this be resolved
and inevitability on the
other? Oh, it's a folk tale.
It'll be resolved. Don't worry
about it. Uh, uh, and we have,
and we have this suspense, as
I say, between expectation,
the possibility of violation
and simply not knowing. Ah,
okay. Now, so we continue. I
cannot help you says neato the car.
I don't want to get dirty. I cannot help.
You said speed of the car. I am too busy.
I am very sad.
Then a little car pulls up.
I think it's wonderful because you know,
it's pulls,
it pulls up just like God and we're
being pulled up short. And there isn't,
it seems to me that there's another
crisis of expectation in this line is that
especially as a toddler,
I need to negotiate that expression.
Idiomatically you know,
I'm three years old, maybe.
I don't know what pulls up
means, you know, it's a strange,
you know, I mean, it, it,
it, it's probably not very good writing
for a toddler precisely for that reason,
but at the same time, you know, it,
it lends itself to us because we recognize
that there's a reading problem or a
piece of the virtual work that needs to
be overcome before you can get on with
it.
You have to find out what pulls up means
in the same way that the adult reader
of pleasures of the imagination has to
find out what plastic means. And, uh,
and as I say,
it's a,
it's a wonderful irony that
this particular difficulty
in reading is precisely
what God, her calls being
pulled up short. All right?
So you solve the problem
and then Lo and behold,
it turns out that it is my friend,
bumpy, bumpy, gives me a push.
He pushes and pushes and I'm
on my way. Thank you. Bumpy.
I called that you're welcome.
Says Bumpy.
And now I think we got
another expectation.
This is the kind of story that has
a moral, it's a feel good story.
Uh, there is, you know,
something good has happened. Uh,
there is this sense of reciprocity is
established between the tow truck, uh,
and the person who helps the tow
truck, uh, out of being stuck, uh,
of,
of a fine sense of reciprocity.
So the expectation is that
there will be a moral,
the tension or a suspense is
what will the moral be. Yeah.
There are a variety of ways. In
other words, in which this story,
just like the rime of the ancient
mariner, good end. I mean, it's not,
it's by no means clear that the rime of
the ancient mariner, we'll end budget,
you know,
love all things great and small things
that could have ended any number of other
ways. Uh, and just so this story
could end a number of ways.
It happens to end now that's
what I call a friend. Well, fine,
the moral is that reciprocity
is friendship and good all,
all to the good. But
as I say, there's that,
there's a moment of suspense
in the expectation at the
point in the text when we
expect a moral,
but we don't know what the moral
is going to be. So once again,
there's a kind of,
there's that moment of suspense that
the reader is able to get through with a
kind of pleasurable excitement and
then overcome as the moral is actually
revealed. All right? Now. So even
Tony, the tow truck in other words,
is not absolutely culinary and can be a
and can be treated in ways that I hope
shed some light on, uh, the reading
process. All right? Very quickly,
uh,
the time is up.
So let me conclude by saying that if
there is this remarkable distinction
between God and easier between cannons,
where the methodology of God seems to
impose on us a traditional cannon and the
methodology of Eser seems to
impose on us and innovative cannon,
isn't there some relief
in historicism after all?
Because the whole point of historicism
as got him or herself puts it is that it
lets the cannon B,
we're not interested in establishing a,
a,
a principle of value that shapes a canon.
We're interested in hearing everybody on
his or her own terms and letting those
texts be,
in other words,
doesn't historicism open the cannon and
indeed make the process of reading the
experience of reading, archival, uh, and,
and omnivorous rather than canonical.
You know,
if every text just is what it is and we
can't bring a methodologically speaking
any kind of preconception to bear on
what's a good text or what's a bad case,
haven't we solved the problem of the
limitation imposed on the reader by any
kind of cannon formation?
Well,
only I say in conclusion,
if we can distinguish between meaning
and significance. In other words,
only if we really are sure that the
historicist act of is effective and works.
If I know the meaning of a
text, well fine. Then later on,
if I wish I can establish a Canon
by saying certain texts have certain
significance and those are the texts
that I care about and water rate.
But I can only do that if I can
distinguish between meaning and cigarette.
But if meaning and significance
bleed into each other, what I'm in,
what I'm going to be doing is
establishing a canon as it were,
unconsciously or 70 consciously,
I'm going to say, oh,
this is just what the text means.
But at the same time,
I'll be finding ways without realizing it,
of affirming certain kinds of meaning,
uh, and discrediting certain other kinds
of meaning. Um, all the while saying,
oh, it's just meaning I'm not, I'm, I'm
not doing that. Uh, and that would if,
but if in fact my reading practice can
be shown not clearly to distinguish
between meaning and significance,
well then that's what would happen.
Uh,
so it's still up in the air and it's
still perhaps in escapable that we read as
it were.
Canonically uh,
but I think what is shown by thinking
of various approaches to hermeneutics in
these terms,
I think what's shown is that there is
a relationship between methodology and
Canon formation that
certain things follow, uh,
from our assumptions about how to read,
uh,
evaluation,
would seem rather at a distant remove
from simple considerations of how to read.
But in fact, I think we've shown that
evaluation is in one way or another,
implicit in certain
methodological premises as they
establish themselves in the
work of these various writers.
Okay. Thank you very much.